CBS news political correspondent ed
O'Keefe is here with each party's
priorities if they win control of the
Congress at good morning morning are we
ready yeah we are ready it's sleep this
weekend yeah I'm gonna take a nap
tomorrow for the first time if the polls
are to be believed if they're to be
believed this time looks like the
Democrats will get it with the hair on
their chinny chin chin right so what are
what are their priorities well if
they're if Democrats retake control of
the house yes they have said they want
to focus on things like finding a way to
get an agreement with the President on
infrastructure spending can we repave
the roads rebuild the airports maybe get
that tunnel built here in New York that
everyone's been asking for they want to
focus on things like protecting dreamers
and figuring out if there is a
compromise again with Republicans on
immigration reform that's been a big
priority for them you may see them push
for things like rebuilding that you're
reauthorizing the Voting Rights Act or
even codifying transgender rights these
are issues that have come up over the
course of their campaign that are
important to their base one thing we
also will see them do there's been a lot
of talk about it investigate the
administration in ways that Congress is
supposed to oversee the executive branch
but they're gonna have a conflict among
themselves about how far you go with
that and whether it leads ultimately to
the I word the I word and if Republicans
keep the Senate that's if Republicans
keep the Senate is expected I mean
you're gonna they're gonna keep doing
what Mitch McConnell calls the personnel
business they're gonna get confirming
Republican or conservative leaning
justices the federal courts and they're
probably going to have to confirm as
many as maybe six or seven new cabinet
secretaries and top ambassadors there's
been talk about change at the Justice
Department the Interior Department and
other places there going to be a UN
Ambassador that can take several weeks
of the Senate's time is there that could
take them all the way to Easter
can you go back to the i-word for a
second do you think that kind of talk
gets you anywhere doesn't get me
anywhere I get some generic you well I
mean look in some parts of the country
it was a topic of conversation during
primaries for Democratic candidates
running for Congress
but overall the party understands that's
not enough to get you elect you gotta
you got to show people what you're for
and going after the president for two
years isn't necessarily enough in this
day and age and we also wish the malla
report will come out somewhere a course
of all this which will change that whole
conversation completely
but what other kinds of things that
could Democrats investigate that
wouldn't be seen as excessively
political you'll start with the fact
that the the president's family company
in some ways is doing business with the
government
you know Trump hotel the fact that the
Secret Service has to rent space from
Trump Tower in down at mar-a-lago
they're gonna look into things that
happen at the EPA questions about
whether or not there should be a
citizenship question on the 2020 census
the administration's pushing for that
some in Congress don't want it basically
every week once they get started if they
get control there will be some kind of
investigation that's coming out people
being dragged before Congress and you
know a lot of questions asked all right
ed we'll see you soon enough go back to
the cot we have that for you in the is
that nap room